Casi empatado con Francia, Alemania es el
país de toda la Unión Europea que más presupuesto
militar tiene. Según los datos recogidos
por el Banco Mundial, casi una cuarta parte
de todo el gasto militar de los países que
integran el club comunitario corresponde a
las fuerzas armadas alemanas.
Hablamos de la Bundeswehr , que literalmente
podría traducirse como Defensa Federal.
Queridos amigos, amigas, Alemania es uno de
los países con más tradición militar de
todo el planeta, lo que, como todos sabéis,
no ha sido algo que haya traído consigo grandes
alegrías para la historia de la humanidad.
Pero, evidentemente, la situación hoy en
día es completamente distinta.
(La Bundeswehr fue fundada en 1955, 10 años
después de la caída del régimen nazi y
del fin de la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Durante ese lapso de tiempo, el Consejo de
Control Aliado que controlaba el país tras
la gran guerra prohibió que el país tuviera
fuerzas armadas propias, y desmanteló y declaró
ilegal cualquier actividad militar relacionada
con la antigua Wehrmacht, las fuerzas armadas
de la Alemania nazi.
Eso fue así hasta que en 1955 esa prohibición
fue levantada y la Alemania Federal fundó
las Fuerzas Armadas que conocemos actualmente.)
Claro que desde entonces ha llovido mucho.
Durante estos casi 70 años el ejército alemán
ha pasado por al menos siete grandes reformas,
tanto estructurales como estratégicas:
De la primera orientación basada en las propias
fuerzas armadas norteamericanas a las dos
últimas que se han traducido en una enorme
reducción de tamaño. Fijaos.
Tan sólo entre finales de los 80 y mediados
de los 90, coincidiendo, lógicamente, con
el colapso de la Unión Soviética y el fin
de la guerra fría, la Bundeswehr [PRON: Búndesvea]
perdió unos 150 mil soldados.
En total, hasta el día de hoy, las fuerzas
armadas de la Alemania occidental, hoy Alemania
a secas, han visto reducirse su tamaño en
un 60%.
Claro, que esto no tiene por qué ser algo
malo. Si algo caracteriza a los ejércitos
modernos es que, gracias a las nuevas capacidades
tecnológicas, necesitan muchos menos efectivos.
El problema es que esas capacidades tecnológicas
exigen un montón de recursos:
Y la pregunta… es, ¿se ha hecho este esfuerzo
en Alemania? ¿Cuenta la mayor potencia de
la Unión Europea con unas fuerzas armadas
bien equipadas y capaces de llevar a cabo
despliegues y misiones complejas? ¿Están
las fuerzas armadas de Alemania preparadas
para entrar en guerra?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1 (DE PERFIL A LOS ASUNTOS MILITARES)
Alemania es con diferencia la primera potencia
económica de toda Europa y en términos de
PIB la cuarta de todo el mundo, tan solo por
detrás de Estados Unidos, China y Japón.
Sin embargo, a pesar de su fuerza económica
y de tener unas cuentas públicas que están
entre las más saneadas del viejo continente,
el esfuerzo en defensa de Alemania apenas
supone poco más del 1% de su Producto Interior
Bruto.
Y aunque el gasto comenzó a incrementarse
tras la anexión rusa de Crimea - bajo el
liderazgo por cierto de la entonces ministra
de defensa, Ursula Von der Layen, todavía
sigue muy por debajo del 2% que como sabéis
exige la OTAN a sus países miembros.
Algo que bueno, tampoco debería llamarnos
mucho la atención: prácticamente ningún
integrante de la OTAN cumple con ese requisito,
y al fin y al cabo se supone que la defensa
de Europa se llevaría a cabo de forma colectiva.
Sin embargo, el problema que tiene Alemania
- y que también tienen otros muchos países
- es que a pesar de gastarse más de 50 mil
millones de euros cada año, esta cifra se
destina casi por completo a salarios, estructuras
desastrosamente planificadas y muchos gastos
corrientes y burocráticos.
Para colmo esta enorme burocracia y los interminables
procesos de contratación hacen que la llegada
de nuevo equipamiento se demore mucho en el
tiempo o simplemente se quede en stand-by.
Es decir, el problema en Alemania no solo
es que apenas destinen a defensa poco más
del 1% de su PIB, sino sobre todo que la mayor
parte de ese dinero se destina a engordar
estructuras ineficientes que nada, absolutamente
nada tienen que ver con las capacidades operativas.
Por ser gráficos, una parte sustancial del
dinero se destina a pagar los salarios a señores
de 50 y muchos años, en muchos casos seguramente,
con abultadas barrigas cerveceras cuyo trabajo
consiste en pasarse el día en una mesa de
oficina.
Así que, claro, en el caso alemán no se
debería hablar tanto de la “falta de esfuerzo”
en defensa como sobre todo de la mala inversión
y planificación de las fuerzas armadas. Al
fin y al cabo 50.000 millones de euros no
son precisamente poco dinero.
Es mucho más dinero de lo que cada año se
gasta en defensa Corea del Sur, casi duplica
lo que se gasta Australia y más que duplica
el presupuesto de Israel.
Y sí lo sé, Alemania es muuucho, muchísimo
más grande que Israel o Corea del Sur. Pero
aquí hablamos fundamentalmente de capacidades
operativas. Y como veréis Alemania está
muy por detrás de estos dos países.
El problema tiene que ver en gran medida con
este gráfico. Fijaos.
Tan solo el 18% del gasto militar alemán
se invierte en equipos militares. Una cifra
que también está por debajo del mínimo
del 20% que marca la OTAN.
El caso es que precisamente por su pasado
histórico, los políticos alemanes siempre
se han mostrado reacios a comprar armas.
(Socialmente el gasto en defensa tampoco es
una baza electoral. Según un sondeo realizado
en 2017, apenas el 9% de los alemanes consideraban
importante aumentar el gasto en defensa frente
al 91% que lo consideraba irrelevante, inadecuado
o no tenía opinión.
La postura alemana desde la posguerra ha tenido
en la diplomacia blanda su gran apuesta en
política exterior. Una postura que como se
ha demostrado con Ucrania puede tener agujeros.)
El caso es que esta falta de gasto en equipamiento
militar ha hecho de Alemania un país altamente
de la OTAN, o mejor dicho, de Estados Unidos
para los asuntos militares.
Al fin y al cabo, Alemania es tras Japón
el segundo país del mundo con más instalaciones
militares estadounidenses.
Y por curioso que os pueda resultar, tiene
estacionados en su territorio a muchos más
soldados americanos que los que, por ejemplo,
hay en Corea del Sur, un país que, recordemos,
está técnicamente en guerra. Hablamos en
total de más de 35.000 efectivos.
Resumiendo: la mala planificación, la falta
de gasto en equipamiento y la dependencia
de Estados Unidos se ha traducido en una extrema
dejadez, en unas Bundeswehr [PRON: Búndesvea]
en un estado lamentable. Y no, no estamos
exagerando lo más mínimo.
(“No importa adónde mires, hay disfunción”
- Oficial alemán de alto rango en el cuartel
general de la Bundeswehr)
Con semejante percal, tras la invasión rusa
de Ucrania, los políticos alemanes de repente
parecen haberse dado cuenta de que la guerra
en Europa no es un escenario completamente
descartable. O cuanto menos que la disuasión
europea no vale de mucho.
Esta es una situación que simple y llanamente
ha pillado por sorpresa a los mandamases de
Berlín. A día de hoy de tener que entrar
en combate es posible que la Bundeswehr [PRON:
Búndesvea] apenas pudiera soportar unos pocos
días de combate. Y ojo que esto no es algo
que digamos solo nosotros. Fijaos.
(“El alemán despreocupado, rodeado de amigos,
con un nivel de vida en aumento, sin preocupaciones
por la seguridad, y que piensa que si hay
un problema los estadounidenses se encargarán
de ello, es cosa del pasado”. - Ekkehard
Brose, presidente de la Academia Federal de
Estudios de Seguridad)
(“Los alemanes se adormecieron en una falsa
sensación de seguridad, con la creencia de
que nunca habría otra guerra en Europa. […] El
resultado es que durante dos generaciones
hemos olvidado cómo defendernos”. - Armin
Papperger, director ejecutivo del fabricante
de armas Rheinmetall.)
El caso es que para solucionar esta larga
decadencia militar, de la cual hablaremos
con todo detalle a continuación, el nuevo
gobierno de Scholz anunció un presupuesto
extraordinario histórico para modernizar
las fuerzas armadas.
Seguro, seguro que la mayoría de vosotros
recordáis esta noticia:
(Alemania impulsará el gasto militar en el
último cambio histórico
Alemania canalizará 100.000 millones de euros
este año hacia un fondo para modernizar el
ejército - Bloomberg)
Además, el gobierno de Scholz también se
ha comprometido a alcanzar el 2% del PIB en
gasto militar anual para el año 2024.
La cuestión es…. ¿Cómo de difícil es
realmente la tarea que tiene Alemania por
delante para poner al día sus fuerzas armadas?
¿Cuáles han sido los efectos de tanta dejadez
en defensa? ¿Cuáles deben ser las prioridades
de Alemania a la hora de invertir todo ese
dinero en los próximos años?
Pues bien…. Veámoslo.
T2 (UN EJÉRCITO EN RUINAS)
El antaño temido ejército alemán ahora
es poco más que un montón de tanques, aviones,
helicópteros y submarinos que, en muchos
casos, no pueden disparar, ni volar ni tampoco
navegar.
Y ojo que estas fueron, básicamente, las
conclusiones del socialdemócrata Hans-Peter
Bartels, ex-comisario para las fuerzas armadas
del Bundestag -el parlamento alemán- tras
realizar un extenso informe en 2019 sobre
las capacidades militares del país. Un informe
repleto de conclusiones demoledoras.
(El informe sirvió para plasmar una realidad
incómoda para el gobierno: el ejército alemán
carece incluso de equipos críticos suficientes
como chalecos antibalas, equipos de visión
nocturna, helicópteros de transporte o radios
para comunicaciones seguras. Y la escasez
no es algo puntual, sino estructural.
Tanto es así que, por poneros un ejemplo,
en una visita de funcionarios estadounidenses
a Lituania estos se quedaron consternados
al ver que el personal de la Bundeswehr se
comunicaba con teléfonos móviles inseguros
por no contar con suficientes radios militares
encriptadas.)
(“No había ni un soldado alemán familiarizado
con el sistema de radio utilizado allí o
que hubiera sido instruido para saber usarlo.
[...] Cuando se trata de equipamiento disponible
en ejercicios internacionales, la Bundeswehr
suele ser el ‘eslabón más débil de la
cadena’”. - Informe del parlamento alemán)
Y esto no es todo. De todo el equipamiento
militar que tiene Alemania en sus inventarios,
solo una pequeña fracción está listo para
el despliegue.
Y luego una buena parte del material que tienen
en funcionamiento no ha cumplido las expectativas
a la hora de realizar operaciones.
La lista de decepciones en el inventario alemán
es larga, muy pero que muy larga.
Por ejemplo, tenemos el caso de la fragata
de clase F-125 Baden Württemberg .
Una nueva clase de fragatas de la que el gobierno
alemán compró cuatro unidades en 2007 y
que después de años de retrasos y enormes
sobrecostes, fueron entregadas a la Armada
con sobrepeso y muchas limitaciones operativas
respecto al proyecto original.
Algo que ha imposibilitado que las fragatas
a día de hoy cumplan con la función para
la que fueron ideadas. Incluso, tuvieron que
ser devueltas al fabricante una vez entregadas
para hacer modificaciones, algo que nunca
antes había pasado en la historia de Alemania.
(La Armada alemana decidió devolver su nueva
fragata sobredimensionada al fabricante naval
esta Navidad - The Drive)
Pero esperad porque hay mucho más.
Un batallón de Panzergrenadiers que participaban
en un ejercicio de la OTAN en Noruega se vieron
faltos de gafas de visión nocturna y ametralladoras
MG3, y… bueno, el resultado es tan chistoso
como bochornoso.
(Alemania “no puede explicar” el uso de
palos de escoba en lugar de ametralladoras
en un ejercicio de la OTAN - Washington Post)
[En un ejercicio de la OTAN. De locos]
Y ojo porque lo más lamentable de esa historia
es que para poder participar en el ejercicio
tuvieron que recabar prestados más de 14.300
equipos de 56 unidades distintas de la Bundeswehr
[PRON: Búndesvea], y aún con esas se quedaron
cortos.
Y por supuesto esto no es una excepción,
es la tónica en cualquier rama del ejército,
sea de tierra, mar o aire.
¿Queréis otro ejemplo? Solo 9 de sus 51
helicópteros de ataque Tiger y menos del
30 por ciento de sus cazas Eurofighter y Tornado
podían volar a finales de 2018.
¿El motivo? La falta de mantenimiento y de
piezas de recambio disponibles en los stocks
de las fuerzas armadas hacen que los ya de
por sí escasos equipos hayan terminado almacenados
como si fueran una especie de reserva inoperativa.
Tanto es así que la fuerza aérea, la Luftwaffe,
ha llegado a ver renuncias de pilotos que
se han ido frustrados porque no podían volar.
(Los pilotos alemanes no están recibiendo
suficientes horas de vuelo
El problema es que la Luftwaffe no tiene suficientes
aviones capaces de volar para que sus pilotos
vuelen. - National Interest)
Ya me diréis para qué demonios queréis
pilotos que no pueden volar.
Y seguimos porque tres cuartas partes de lo
mismo pasa con los tanques Leopard 2, la joya
de la corona de la infantería pesada alemana
y de los cuales solo la mitad están operativos.
Y más, solo 150 de los 350 blindados Puma
están listos para usarse.
De los 15 aviones de transporte A400M, solo
tres estaban en condiciones de volar en 2018,
y hubo una temporada en la que ni uno solo
de los seis submarinos alemanes podía navegar.
¿Entendéis ahora por qué Alemania no ha
enviado casi nada de equipamiento a Ucrania
para apoyar su resistencia contra la invasión
rusa? [Más allá de que tampoco parezca hacerles
mucha gracia] Si apenas tienen equipamiento
funcional para ellos, ¡como para encima regalárselo
a otro país!
(“En el corto plazo no tenemos nada disponible
que podamos proporcionar realmente de forma
rápida y puntual.” - Annalena Baerbock,
Ministra de Exteriores de Alemania)
El caso es que, al margen de esto, todas estas
carencias conllevan también una clara falta
de entrenamiento y preparación de la tropa,
algo que, por supuesto, también afectaría
y mucho a su moral en caso de combate.
La huida de pilotos de la Luftwaffe es solo
un ejemplo, pero si miramos las cifras de
reclutamiento lo vemos todavía más claro.
(El ejército alemán lucha por atraer a los
tan necesitados reclutas
El número de nuevos soldados cayó el año
pasado a un récord histórico de 20.000 - FT)
Pensadlo un momento, con este percal, ¿quién
va a estar motivado para meterse en las fuerzas
armadas?
Pues bien, la cuestión que muchos seguro
que os estáis preguntando llegados a este
punto es… ¿Tiene acaso solución todo este
desaguisado?
¿Son 100.000 millones de presupuesto extraordinario
suficientes para reconstruir unas fuerzas
armadas que están hechas trizas? ¿En qué
debería invertir Alemania todo ese dinero?
Pues bien, descubrámoslo.
T3 (¿UNA LECCIÓN APRENDIDA?)
Con todo lo que os acabamos de contar seguro,
seguro que la mayoría lo tenéis muy claro:
las fuerzas armadas alemanas están obsoletas.
Y no solo obsoletas, sino en muchos casos
en estado casi decrépito.
Y eso a pesar de gastarse más de 50 mil millones
de euros cada año. De locos.
Pues bien esto es precisamente lo que explica
el aparente e histórico cambio de paradigma
que Alemania parece querer dar a su política
de defensa.
Eso y por supuesto también los 100 mil millones
de euros que han aprobado para reconstruir
sus fuerzas armadas, lo que en el curso de
los próximos cinco años implicará cumplir
con el compromiso del 2% del PIB de gasto
militar en defensa, una le añadimos el gasto
anual regular.
La cuestión es… ¿en qué deberían gastarse
toda esta pasta? ¿Cuál será la lista de
la compra de Berlín con una cantidad de dinero
que equivale prácticamente a todo lo que
una economía como Ecuador produce durante
un año?
Pues bien, por ahora la lista de la compra
para la defensa alemana es prácticamente
un secreto.
Sin embargo, hay varias pistas y varias conjeturas
que podemos hacer sobre qué equipos sí o
sí estarán -o deberían estar- entre las
próximas adquisiciones alemanas.
(Hasta el momento lo que sí ha hecho público
Alemania es que comprará 35 cazas de quinta
generación F-35, que es considerado el caza
más avanzado del mundo, para reemplazar sus
viejos tornados y con ellos poder tener la
superioridad aérea en caso de conflicto.
También adquirirán 15 Eurofighters con capacidad
de guerra electrónica, y drones armados.
Equipamiento que en algunos casos fue anunciado
antes de lanzar el fondo especial.
En total Alemania espera gastar unos 41.000
de esos 100.000 millones de euros en la fuerza
aérea, y unos 19.000 millones en la Armada,
con los que se espera que adquieran submarinos,
fragatas y corbetas, así como barcos de combate
multipropósito.)
Por su parte el ejército de tierra se llevaría
unos 17.000 millones de euros en equipamiento,
lo que se utilizarán prácticamente por completo
para actualizar y poner operativos los blindados,
tanques y artillería que ya tiene el ejército
alemán.
Y por supuesto la última pata sobre la mesa
que Alemania busca solucionar con esta enorme
cantidad de dinero es la falta de suministros
de equipamientos básicos.
Según Aylin Matlé, experta en seguridad
del Consejo Alemán de Relaciones Exteriores,
casi 21.000 millones serían destinados tanto
a nuevas tecnologías de comunicaciones, como
radios seguras y ciberseguridad, como al propio
equipamiento personal de los soldados.
La cuestión es, ¿será todo esto suficiente?
Pues seguramente no. Como ya habéis visto,
el estado de la Bundeswehr es complicado,
muy complicado.
Pero sin duda marcará un antes y un después
para el ejército alemán, que deberá ir
acompañado, sí o sí, de una reestructuración
del gasto para eliminar todas las estructuras
militares zombies que consumen muchos recursos
pero que no son operativas.
Estructuras que son las culpables de que el
dinero no haya ido a parar a tecnología militar
y mantenimiento, sino a otros menesteres.
Y amigos, amigas, esta tarea es mucho más
importante que simplemente gastar más y llegar
al 2% del PIB. Como, por ejemplo, hace Grecia.
La cuestión es, ¿están los políticos alemanes
dispuestos a hacerlo? Al final, las fuerzas
armadas suelen ser uno de los mayores empleadores
en casi cualquier país, y meter la mano en
este sentido suele toparse con grandes resistencias.
Y todo eso por no olvidar lo difícil que
es superar viejos vicios. Fijaos.
N6 (11 de julio de 2022: Alemania acusada
de hacer recortes furtivos en defensa. El
presupuesto de defensa alemán disminuye una
vez que se elimina el impacto del fondo especial
de 100 000 millones de euros, según los documentos
oficiales citados por el periódico Bild.
Los críticos dicen que el fondo único está
ocultando los recortes en el gasto recurrente.
The Telegraph)
Pero, llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti.
¿Sabías que las fuerzas armadas alemanas
estaban en un estado tan lamentable? ¿Crees
que la solución para solucionarlo pasa por
meter más dinero o por el contrario crees
que 50.000 millones de euros al año es suficiente,
y el problema es cómo se ha estado gastando?
Déjanos tus opiniones aquí abajo, en los
comentarios. Y si te ha gustado este vídeo
no olvides darle like y suscribirte a nuestro
canal, dándole también a la campanita para
no perderte ninguna novedad.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí. Un saludo
y hasta la próxima.